[Musique]
Chantal Hébert Michel David Véronique
prince bonsoir bonsoir
comment on disait Véronique plutôt dans
l'émission le caucus
en deux trois deux temps trois
mouvements Marc Tanguy a été désigné
chef on va l'écouter premier extrait où
il parle des valeurs libérales
bon évidemment ce n'est pas le chef le
nouveau chef ou la nouvelle chef qui
sera élu mais quand même ça peut prendre
un certain temps donc ce que va dire
monsieur tanguet puis il va devenir le
visage de l'opposition ça reste
important premier tour de table sur le
choix Chantal et sur la suite des choses
mais le choix d'abord
le choix est important de façon un petit
peu ironique qui est arrivé que des
chefs intérimaires amènent les parties
dans l'opposition à des meilleurs
résultats que le choix des membres au
moment d'une course au lieu de chefs
remplacé en attendant qu'on choisisse un
dossier c'était présenté
ou avait été couronné le Parti
conservateur avait des meilleurs scores
à cette époque-là
idem dans le quantité fendillon qui
était arrivé on lui a laissé la partie
en meilleure position que ce qui est
arrivé six mois plus tard donc ça compte
mais ce qui compte aussi c'est l'idée
que le chef intégrière finalement se
présente pas la direction du parti pas
parce que c'est permis ou pas permis
mais parce que c'est un mélange de gens
qui est pas particulièrement porteur et
ça permet effectivement quelqu'un de se
construire un avantage à cause de
visibilité du poste ouais Michel David
même s'il y a une possibilité qu'il se
présente mais d'abord je vous entends
sur le choix qu'après on aura le temps
d'élaborer sur sur ça mais sur le choix
Michel d'abord je pense que les libéraux
avaient pas vraiment beaucoup de choix
possibles la majeure partie des vétérans
ont quitté au moment de la dernière
élection et parmi ceux qui restaient
ça se jouait entrevue d'ici entre
monsieur Fortin et important et Monsieur
tanguet et je pense que les gens avaient
plus l'impression que André Fortin se
lancerait dans la course de pour obtenir
le poste de façon permanente que
Monsieur Tanguy et
honnêtement monsieur Fortin
disons c'est le coach de Trudeau à la
dernière campagne électorale c'est si le
parti de Beral veut se rapprocher des
francophones il va falloir qu'ils se
donnent un air un peu plus nationaliste
et je pense pas que monsieur Fortin est
capable d'incarner ça ok mais revenons à
revenons à tanguer je vais vous en
parler puis je vais vous faire entendre
monsieur Fortin plus tard Véronique
prince donc dans le caucus c'était comme
une lettre à la poste c'était presque
une évidence oui effectivement puis le
choix est vraiment pas surprenant en
fait parce que Mark Tanguay répondait
aux critères qui recherchait pour le
poste de chef intérimaire parce que Marc
Tanguay c'est quelqu'un qui est déjà
très ancré dans le parti il a été
président du parti sans compter le comté
de la fontaine et celui qui compte
actuellement le plus de membres et on
sait qu'un des rôles du travail de chef
intérimaire ça va être de freiner
l'hémorragie de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait pas davantage de membres qui partent
qui ait d'autres associations de comté
qui deviennent du Sud au fil du temps
donc lui doit tenir ça à bout de bras et
comme il est très connecté sur le
terrain ça va lui permettre de le faire
parallèlement à son rôle d'opposition
officielle parce que ça va être ça il va
devoir débattre tous les jours au
Parlement en même temps et il est
reconnu comme étant un excellent
débatteur ces adversaires trouvent que
c'est un dur négociateur qui les
implacable en fait qui veut rien
entendre qui collabore pas ça c'est la
vie de ces adversaires mais en même
temps le rôle d'opposition officielle
devant un François Legault qui est très
fort et qui est très populaire c'est
peut-être ça aussi que le parti idéal
c'est ça
joueur défensif première tâche qui s'est
donné c'est d'aller chercher madame
Nicole ça sera symbolique on va
la porte au-delà du fait que la porte
pour Marie-Claude demeure ouverte que la
main est tendue moi j'ai l'intention de
contacter Marie-Claude Nicole rapidement
pour aller m'asseoir avec elle puis
avoir une bonne discussion avec
Marie-claude je vais d'abord et avant
tout là aller prendre mon café avec
Marie-claude si elle le désire moi je
vais l'appeler je vais lui offrir puis
vous me permettrait d'avoir cette
discussion là avec elle
chez David on voyait là parce que il
devra avoir des talents de négociateur
de leader de rassemblage on voyait qu'il
se donne ça comme première mission là
évidemment oui et j'ai pas l'impression
que ça va être très compliqué dans le
cas de Madame Nicole il y avait je pense
beaucoup de d'animosités personnelles
entre madame Nicole et Madame Anglade là
madame manglas est parti et je pense pas
que ça soit très long à négocier je
pense pas non plus qu'on va lui donner
je voyais d'ailleurs sur l'image
monsieur Benjamin qui a hérité ou qui
héritera de la troisième vice-présidente
puis vous êtes Chantal est le moins
disons le gros bout du bâton aujourd'hui
avec Dominique Anglade qui était
irréparable tandis que avec Marc Tanguy
il y a beaucoup plus d'atomes crochus
parce que des petites ensemble et tout
ça donc ce serait pas surprenant
effectivement qu'elle accepte davantage
de parler avec Martin gay très bien
Michel en a parlé monsieur Fortin
monsieur Fortin on a eu l'impression à
un certain moment que c'était son moment
puis finalement il avait dit pour des il
a fait une conférence de presse je me
souviens pour des raisons familiales
jeunes enfants je n'irai pas je ne ferai
pas partie de cette course pour le Parti
libéral du Québec là c'est un peu
passez-moi l'expression anglaise
maintenant
on se dit si lui a un avenir c'est
maintenant qui doit accélérer Chantal
[Musique]
la maison officielle il y a deux ans et
demi c'est à dire que c'était pour des
raisons familiales et c'est vrai qu'il y
a des jeunes enfants mais en même temps
il y a deux ans et demi là quand vous
regardiez les conditions là il y avait
la CAQ qui venait d'être élu en 2018 on
est en pleine pandémie la popularité
était au sommet déjà on pensait que la
CAF est repartait pour un deuxième
mandat alors là de se dire ben moi je me
lance dans ce défi là de devenir chef du
Parti libéral qui est à reconstruire on
peut penser qu'à ce moment-là peut-être
que ça lui tait pas là les conditions
sont quand même différentes parce que
après deux mandats après 8 ans il va y
avoir une usure du gouvernement de la
CAN donc à ce moment-là ce que les gens
vont avoir les yeux les oreilles plus
ouverts à voir qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans l'opposition et aux parties
libérale
Michel vous disiez tout à l'heure
il a travaillé dans une préparation
entre autres avec Monsieur Trudeau donc
ça le vous avez pas vous n'êtes pas allé
aussi loin mais ça sous-entendait
attention il a il n'a pas donc la
québécois 100% vous vous croyez qu'il
part avec ce n’est pas parti d'abord
mais il partirait avec ce boulet d'abord
il y a pas juste servi de d'instructeurs
monsieur Trudeau au moment de la
dernière campagne électorale lui est
issu de la filière libérale alliée était
dans les cabinets libéraux de Jean
Lapierre de Paul Martin c'est un
fédéraliste inconditionnel mais je pense
que il y a que ça au Parti libéral mais
c'est pas comment dire c'est pas lui qui
va incarner le renouveau et le
rapprochement avec les francophones mon
impression est si incarne possible au
départ voyez c'est on dit toujours hier
il ressemble à Robert borasa puis c'est
vrai que même physiquement des fois on
trouve les une ressemblance mais quand
on parlait beaucoup de lui j'en avais
discuté avec des des proches de Monsieur
Bourassa à l'époque qui disait peut-être
qu'il y a le nez et les épaules un peu
votés mais c'est tout il y a pas la même
fibre que Monsieur Bourassa est leur
esprit eux ça n'en faisait pas un
comment dire un prétendant idéal loin de
là
ceci étant dit les libéraux vont choisir
qui veulent mais honnêtement je suis pas
certain que ça serait le meilleur choix
pour eux le problème c'est qu'il y
auront peut-être pas tant de choix que
ça ouais mais restons là-dessus chanter
est-ce que ça pour vous pour faire des
gains au Québec au sein de la des
francophones des fédéralises des
libéraux c'est un désavantage que d'être
issu de la filière fédérale si on peut
dire
jusqu'à un certain point mais soyons
cellule juste un truc d'eau gagne plus
de siège auquel dans le Québec
francophone c'est aussi que de parties
libéral du Québec alors faut quand même
relativiser la chose on parle de Joël
lightband qui est un député fédéral et
c'est quand même ça parle de fait qu'on
dit que qui serait un candidat
intéressant parce qu'il est un peu en
rupture avec Monsieur Trudeau alors il y
a de ça là dedans cela dit moi j'ai hâte
de voir combien il va y avoir de
candidats et s'il va y avoir une vraie
course parce que une course sur des deux
chips ça révèle ou pas des gens qui
arrivent qui débarquent qui ont l'air
super intéressant puis au fil de la
course on découvre qui sont ennuyants
comme la pluie puis finalement ils sont
même pas ils devraient même pas être là
souvenez-vous excusez-moi j'entends la
dernière fois tu sens tout le monde
disait ça y est les établissement a
trouvé son candidat puis c'est pas rendu
à la fin
un peu gênant quand même quand on va
chercher quelqu'un qui a pas
d'expérience à l'Assemblée nationale et
je dis la même chose quand les questions
du Parlement fédéral et qu'on a enfin un
aspirant Premier ministre toujours au
lendemain il y a quand même ce style la
seule profession il semble-t-il le
Premier ministre ou personne n'a besoin
de faire d'apprentissage c'est pas
encore étonnant ok
on va écouter monsieur Fortin on va
écouter les d'autres dont vous venez de
parler puis on revient tout de suite
Véronique pour parler de la suite des
choses
mais de toute évidence pour avoir une
pause à la direction intéressante ça
prend des idées ça prend des idées qui
sont pas nécessairement les idées
traditionnelles on peut présenter des
idées complètement audacieuses
complètement nouvelle complètement
différente au parti idéal qui sont en
lien avec nos valeurs il faut un chef
qui comprend les régions il faut un chef
qui sait c'est quoi vivre en région qui
sait c'est quoi la réalité des régions
est-ce qu'il faut que ce chef-là vienne
les régions ce sera la dernière
je ne ferme pas la porte et si je me fie
au dernier message que j'ai reçu il y a
beaucoup de gens qui m'encouragent à
aller de l'avant justement pour avoir
une course où on va débattre des idées
des idées audacieuses
[Musique]
vont passer puis on mais c'est
intéressant parce que tous s'entendent
sur une chose ça prend une vraie course
mais ils ont appris de leur erreur en
2020 parce que ça a été un réel problème
au Parti libéral et ça contribué à cette
espèce d'effondrement qui s'était amorcé
parce que ils ont pas eu de visibilité
encore moins parce qu'on était en pleine
pandémie il y avait pas d'engouement
pour cette course là et c'est seulement
avec de l'engouement qu'on peut attirer
des nouveaux membres alors les gens
n'étaient même plus intéressés à
participer dans les associations de
circonscription et ça va faire partie
justement cette course là du travail de
reconstruction du parti et d'aller
chercher du financement parce que le
Parti libéral on a toujours dit que
c'était le parti le plus riche mais la
réalité c'est que lui aussi commence à
avoir des problèmes de financement parce
qu'il a de la difficulté justement à
tirer les dons à attirer les gens dans
leurs événements et tout ça et il compte
beaucoup sur une course quitte à ce que
des candidats se désistent en cours de
route au moins que ça puisse susciter un
groupe
très bien très bien Michel vous et vous
avez écrit là-dessus ce matin d'autres
l'ont fait depuis plusieurs semaines ça
c'est ça revient j'en ai beaucoup parlé
au lendemain d'élection je posais la
question au chef des deux parties Québec
solidaire particulier quoi est-ce que il
y aura pas une autre tentative il y en
avait une d'alliance qui avait été faite
par
à l'époque par Jean-François lisez
Michel je vous donne la parole on va
voir le sondage pendant que le Cuet
c'est le PQ ont monté chacun dans le
dernier sondage Léger Journal de
Montréal 19 18 alors là les gens disent
bon ben ils devraient ils devraient
fusionner oui à des questions
identitaires mais ça ça peut se régler
autour d'une grandeur Michel vous vous
dites tout ça est un fantasme oui
il a raison la suivante je doute pas que
Monsieur Gabriel nado Dubois monsieur
saint-pierre-la-mondon c'est des gens
qui ont certains pragmatisme regardent
ces chiffres là et se disent bon bah ça
sera peut-être pas de mauvaise idée
exactement ce que Monsieur disait
faisait à l'époque il y avait à l'époque
du côté de Québec solidaire des gens
comme Gabriel ado Dubois comme un
Mercadier qui faisait les mêmes
raisonnements qui faisait regarder le
pour c'est bon pour nous deux mais dans
les deux comme dans le cas de Québec
solidaire ils se sont fait carrément
dire non par leur base le Congrès le qui
devait statuer sur l'alliance a été
mémorable et de violence rare j'avais
jamais vu moi des gens
comment dire autant des tests
et les pékistes ont perçu ça comme une
véritable insulte ce que c'était
d'ailleurs et depuis ce temps-là les
militants pékistes ne veulent pas
entendre parler des solidaires alors
dans les deux cas les chefs le sont pris
avec une base qui veut rien savoir mais
les électeurs des deux parties e sont
dans une très grande proportion d'avis
que il devrait y avoir une alliance
parce qu'il voit les avantages
des objections des militants comment
faire on peut pas passer par dessus la
base militante
solidaire Chantal comment vous voyez ça
maintenant
une fusion je suis comme une chienne je
trouve que ça tient plus fantasme et de
l'addition de sondage que de la réalité
possible une alliance électorale on en
parle souvent on en a pas vu souvent
est-ce que ça fonctionnerait
nécessairement est-ce que de se faire
dire dans une circonscription ou des
gens votent Québec solidaire mais
maintenant vous allez voter pour le PQ
ou à l'inverse pas évident non plus
comment ça marche ça va être débat des
chefs une manière sélectorale qui parle
pour qui et quand il se contredisent
qu'est-ce que les électeurs qui sont à
l'autre bout de l'Alliance sont censés
faire dans ces circonstances là
pas convaincu moi que les électeurs de
Québec solidaires dont presque la moitié
était pas s'identifier pas la
souveraineté suivez nécessairement qui
laisse dans un mariage avec le PQ ouais
c'est c'est pas un détail effectivement
que vous le rappeler aussi Michel ce
matin la je pense c'est 50 huit pour
cent de des électeurs de cœur 54 qui se
disent qu'il voit très oui un référendum
en fait oui le nom est plus fort
pardonnez-moi Véronique sur la colline
ça se parle pas beaucoup là il y en a
pas de dialogue il y en a pas de
discussion en ce moment pour une fusion
même s'il y a plus des gens en avoir
dans le passé en fait ce serait facile
de dire c'est deux parties de gauche
progressistes en faveur de la
souveraineté c'est facile de dire ça
mais la réalité est au niveau des et
elle est idéologique en fait au niveau
des instances il ne s'entendent pas par
exemple sur les seuils d'immigration le
PQ veut les diminuer QS veut les
augmenter c'est quand même un jeu qui
identitaire et sur la prestation du
serment à la reine ça aurait été une
occasion de collaborer ensemble parce
qu'ils étaient d'accord sur le même
point mais ils se sont même pas parlé
là-dessus ce sont même pas
ils se sont pas appelés finalement alors
voyez que il y en a pas finalement de
d'atomes crochus entre les chefs en tout
cas et les instances des deux parties je
fais longtemps qu'on a pas parlé du
serment
[Rires]
ça va revenir très bien ok alors je vous
je vous remercie à vous trois bonne
soirée et à très bientôt au revoir au
revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI